all right y'all
let's
do it
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome to your absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all ripping with griffin
back at it again
and you know
what this episode gonna be about
the pursuit of slappiness
the midnight slap
smith defender
we're gonna be all in that and that's
all i'm gonna talk about today the
oscars what happened
just my thoughts
my analysis maybe some questions from
the chat but
welcome to
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all
turn this mic down
all right anyways welcome to roofing
with griffin thanks for being here
everybody
thanks for being here but before we
begin
we should
take care of some uh business first
let's pay the bills ladies and gentlemen
what do you want to eat tonight maybe
you want a home-cooked favorite but
don't like going to the store doordash
connects you with everything you want
whenever and however you want it get 25
off and zero delivery fees on your first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code griffin
also
coinbase thank you for being a sponsor
coinbase for a limited time new users
can get ten dollars in free bitcoin when
you sign up today at coinbase.com
riffin
griffin
sign up at coinbase.com written griffin
for 10
in free
bitcoin
welcome to the show everybody um i don't
know it's just uh we're live you know i
like doing it live so thank you for
being here
um you know uh you know you know what
i'm gonna talk about today so i'm not
even going like should we not even go
sugar coat nothing and we're gonna just
uh we're gonna get into everything that
happened uh on sunday at the oscars my
thoughts on the whole thing and
and uh just you know about comedy about
the oscars about will smith about you
know what i think about you know comedy
and you know it's just
this has just been on my mind i've been
hot and heavy about it i'm more calm
about it now and then you know also i
don't want to be super crazy when i'm
live and say something off the cuff you
know what i mean uh and we just uh you
know we'll see uh
how this goes all right
so
first of all again once again thank you
for being here um
thanks for being here chat live
um remember i think you know make sure
you hit the subscribe button subscribe
share hit the notifications and i'm here
every week so check me out there i'm
also on twitch guys i twitch live at air
griffin gaming i play a call of duty a
lot i've been playing some elden ring
and i'ma dabble back into destiny so if
you like watching me video game check me
out there at twitch.com
you know switch twitch.tv eric griffin
gaming so i'm there all the time and i
also put my videos up on youtube at eric
griffin gaming too so make sure you
check that
out
all right ladies and gentlemen here we
are
i thought
before i
start talking about
what happened the infamous slap heard
around the world
let me just talk a little bit about
the oscars
um
the oscars the oscars the oscars the
oscars
what does it mean to watch the oscars
what does it mean to any of us really
uh you know back in the day when i was a
kid watching the oscars was like this
big event and they were getting huge
numbers like super bowl numbers back in
the day but you know there was only like
three networks so
that was the biggest thing on tv and
that's what you would watch and so it
became like this big event
that everybody would watch you know you
look forward to it you know i i think
the movies were better i think there
wasn't this you know
need to make movies about tragedy all
the time where every movie has to be a
tragedy every movie has to you know be
about somebody overcoming something
sometimes they just made good movies you
know it could be a mobster movie it
could be a comedy it could be a a great
love story it could be something about
loss but it was like great performances
from great actors great filmmakers
lighting sound costume you know it was
this sort of glamorous event that you
look forward to seeing because one
you know there wasn't as much ex
accessibility to stars as there are now
but when i was a kid you couldn't you
know the only time you would see like
say let's use will smith if to see
someone like will smith when i was a kid
you'd have to look in magazines there
was no internet all right so let's take
there's no internet there's no cell
phones it's just you would look on tv
you would look in magazines if you got
them you'd look in the paper and that's
how you saw celebrities it was the only
way to see them would be on tv and when
you saw celebrities on tv you were just
seeing them in the thing that they were
that they were doing the character they
were playing their tv show or
occasionally there would be some like
you know
a sort of entertainment tonight type of
show that you'd be like ooh you get to
gossip or this person was spotted at so
and so so it became like a thing it was
like an event that you would watch to
see the people that you know and then
the oscars was also it was a great
entertainment show
billy crystal
used to do a great job you do a big
musical number about the movies that
were coming out and you know he would
poke fun at people in like a sort of
like vanilla sort of way and it would be
a great show to watch
everybody was involved and it was like
this you know it is a it's a tv show the
oscars is a tv show
it is a tv show for entertainment
purposes too not only just the idea of
giving out awards and so we would watch
that
and then
over the years and by the way too
i think it was easier for people to
consume
for the masses especially the majority
you know if you were white i'm just
saying i mean it is i'm not trying to
make this about race but i'm just saying
it's just easier when we weren't dealing
with any social issues it was just the
oscars it didn't matter if everybody was
like why everybody was white nobody
cared nobody thought about it nobody
talked about it 80s 90s it wasn't a deal
for
you know on tv this wasn't a thing that
people were talking about all the time
social justice and all this stuff and so
you know maybe you're at home as a
minority like myself and you're sitting
at home and you're thinking you're not
even thinking about it like yeah i don't
see a lot of people of color here you
don't you know you weren't densely
thinking about it but you know and then
it became a thing where you know over
the years this is something that became
a thing i remember when whoopi goldberg
was up for ghost it was the first time i
started to think about it too where i
was like oh yeah hold up a second
who's winning these awards
like uh
you start seeing movies you go when i
started really going to the movies i was
like yeah i do see a lot of
i see a lot of people of color but
oscars come around you don't see that so
this just started to become a thing so
now it's like
you know that's a a factor
that to me
you know affected the oscars
now cut to
the internet cell phones
listen
it's different now
when you watch the oscars now
what are you watching it for because
i don't need to watch it to see my
favorite celebrity i can see my favorite
celebrity right here on this cell phone
i can see him right here
if i want to see like i get to see if i
want to see will smith i can go right to
will smith's instagram where he's got
millions of followers and he puts up
content all the time at his house with
his kids with his wife
he's
making jokes all the time he's like
doing funny skits i have more access to
will smith on my phone than i do when i
watch this show so i so there's no
wow value to it anymore there's no like
ooh
look at that guy
do i want to see what that guy's got
going on
it's just
there's nothing who cares
right so now and then on top of that the
award show itself has turned into
[Music]
it's turned into like this virtue
signaling
sort of like preaching to the choir echo
chamber
of liberal politics all the time
in the past five to ten years you know
it's become that too
and i've talked about this before
it's like
you know 60 70 million people
are you know
voted for trump okay uh
people voted for bush people vote you
know there are republicans there are
conservatives out there who also like
movies
and so they want to see their stars too
but they turn on this television show
and all they're being told is that
they're wrong
uh you know you're wrong your ideas are
wrong your ideals are wrong that
everything about you is wrong from these
celebrities
these rich celebrities who are talking
down to you at home so you're at home in
middle america you know you just you
know what i mean you probably don't even
know a black person in your town if
you're like some you know in some white
area you know you don't maybe you don't
hate black people just not around them
right and you got to turn on the tv and
you got to see people telling you about
stuff that you're like well can i just
watch a show without it being about this
so that took away from the oscars too in
my opinion
so you have so many people just being
like nah don't want to watch that i'll
just find out in the morning on the
internet who won or who didn't win and
then you go i don't even want to watch
these movies anyway you know the movie
that won best picture is it's on it's
not even a movie that you can go you
watch in the movie theater
i think it was in the movie theaters but
it's an apple tv movie okay so you're
talking about
what we consider
a movie going experience it's not even
being celebrated at the oscars anymore
anyway they're trying to move away from
that anyway so you know so now this what
is the show it's my point i'm trying to
make here is what's the show what's the
point of the oscars okay
what's the point of you watching have
you ever asked yourself like why do i
want to watch this well for a long time
it became about watching the best
comedian in the world is going to be the
host or the most popular comedian the
most like whatever groundbreaking
community
that was like a prestigious thing you
had the the actors getting the awards
you could see the outfits the dresses
the suits the the glitz and the glamour
and then you got to see this comedian
that maybe you never got to you never
went out to the clubs you you know see
this person this figure that you know
about it whether it be eddie murphy or
uh you know whoever it is you would
watch this person and that became part
of the thing
and then somewhere along the way
the oscars got super boring
super boring guys
and i'ma tell you and i really think the
reason why the oscars got boring is
because like i said
who cares we can see these people on the
internet so that's not we're not wowed
by that anymore we're not wild by the
movies man go go go google the the the
the movies that have won in the last 10
years and see how much money these
movies have made and that is important
because that's a sign of who's going to
watch these movies
it's like
it's it's ridiculous compared to like
hey a blockbuster movie that is
entertaining to people
you know and yes there are artsy fartsy
types out there who are like well i want
to watch a movie i want to watch a movie
for the artistic value of it and i'm
like that too sometimes i get that and
so this is supposed to be the oscars is
a celebration of art artists right
here's my point
does that need to be televised
does that need to be televised
does the oscars need to be on on tv
like on cbs abc on a major network
no man you know what the oscars is now
the oscars is like a graduation at a
prestigious college
like harvard or columbia right
it's pretty prestigious they might even
have barack obama as the keynote speaker
or elon musk or someone like like
someone super high influential super
successful and rich
that [ __ ] ain't on tv
because we don't care but daycare the
families care those people care these
people are going to be taste makers and
they're going to be the
the leaders of tomorrow at schools like
that
but does it need to be on tv no
because the rest of us are looking at
just like okay they just sucking
themselves off and it's fine
it's fine
like the oscars is just for these people
to celebrate themselves
and we don't care anymore
can we just say that we don't care
anymore if i was up for oscar i would be
so excited to be there but i'm telling
you who cares who's watching the oscars
should be on c-span
do you know how much important [ __ ] goes
on on c-span you all need to go to
c-span one time and see like there'll be
some congressional vote or some hearing
going on that will affect all of our
lives
and no one's watching it but it's on tv
but it's important stuff going on
that's uh
what the oscars are now the oscars
should be on entertainment network it
should be on bravo or something because
it's all about the dresses and who's
wearing what and and what's happening
and then the people that are into that
kind of stuff they have their little
network they can watch it on and we
don't got to worry about it anymore we
don't have to like
because it's like we're at a point like
who cares
the oscars ratings google it
google the oscars ratings
all last year it was at an all time low
every single gear that moves forward we
don't
care
okay
i know covet has to do with some of that
but it's trending in the wrong direction
for the last 10
years
it's not the spectacle that it once was
and they keep trying to make it that
now
here's the thing
you have these comedians
there was a time when chris rock he
hosted i believe it was the mtv music
awards and movie awards whichever one it
was and he was going in on people
and it was like you know
that became the thing like roasting
why do we roast celebrities by the way
at things like this
i personally believe it's because
we want
to humanize them
you know they sit in there like princes
and kings and duchesses and dukes of you
know like they're better than everybody
and the comedian is there to remind them
yo you just an actor homie you're just
an actor and the people at home want to
laugh and you know whatever okay
now
i can fully acknowledge
maybe
you like a big time actor you're about
to receive this award you're like yo do
you got to give me [ __ ] can i just
why are you talking [ __ ] about me can i
just sit here and get my award and hear
speeches and documentary stuff and and a
little skits in between and watch the
host like you know have a little fun
with things and but do you have to [ __ ]
on me
i totally get that feeling
i respect that feeling if i was
graduating you know i wouldn't want the
valedictorian speech to be like oh man
look at eric
barely passed his classes y'all but ah
good job give him his diploma like that
would be messed up you with your family
and friends are here with you they got
the air horns they all like
and you getting clowned at your
graduation
totally would be like i get that energy
of being like yo man can you just give
me my award i don't want this nonsense
going on you know while i'm getting my
award i totally get that i get it
okay
and so now you got this situation where
you know then you got like ricky gervais
at the golden globes who was going in
like
really mean-spirited type of stuff
drinking you know he had this like drink
and he was just going in on people to
the point where these celebrities were
if you you should google bruce willis
bruce willis ricky's your face bruce
willis comes out after ricky gervais
calls him uh ashton kutcher's dad
and it's in rook and bruce willis is
like oh man he looks over at him like
ha
ah like i want to beat this dude's ass
you know what i mean
he like he was going in ricky gervais
called the sex and the cities ladies old
he was going in on them airbrushing the
pictures we know how old you are
i mean it was just non-stop just tearing
people down for four years right
and then the reward shows just like
that's it now it's turned into that
listen i don't i don't necessarily think
that that's the kind of comedy that you
want to have that's not the the oscars
and the award shows of old
it's not prestigious anymore and we have
turned it into a roast and you know i
don't necessarily like that either like
i want the comic to be up there be funny
poke fun at people in a way that they
don't feel bad but it don't even matter
because the people are sensitive anyway
they don't want they don't they don't
want the comedian to say anything they
just don't but here's the thing what is
the point of watching uh oscars
least when you watch the grammys
they're songs people are singing so you
can see like ooh that's my favorite art
they're gonna do their song and they got
the stage set up
there's pyrotechnics and dancers and
you're like wow this is great
i could actually remember great grammy
moments
you know i remember prince doing purple
rain on the grammys and it was like wow
you know what i mean i can remember
grammy moments i remember michael
jackson winning all those awards i
remember you know i can just think back
to times and the grammys because it sat
with me more because i remember those
songs i remember the performances the
oscars man i couldn't tell you who won
best picture last year homie i don't
even know who won last year i don't know
i don't i couldn't tell your best
screenplay from last year nobody nobody
cares about this stuff so what's the
point of watching the oscars it's the
comedian
you're watching for like like this just
and that's why they should have had
you're supposed to have someone like
kevin hart you're supposed to have
someone like whoever the biggest comic
in the world is at the time that's the
person you want on the oscars because
that's bringing the casual viewer to be
like oh let's see what's going on here
that's gone it's completely gone now we
live in this sort of woke environment of
like where all the movies have to be
tragedies and you have to be making a
point in the movie to to even be
nominated now or it's got to be some
white guilt movie you you know once
again we got to show white people how
terrible they were
a thousand years ago
or well let's not let's be real it could
be 50 years ago y'all were terrible but
still the point is
where's the entertainment value in any
of that man where where is it
okay
so now cut to
this year
and let's
get
to it okay
cut to this year
and this is what we all want to talk
about
slap gate
pursuit of slappiness
here comes midnight slaps
[Music]
i don't know
here we are dude
i have so many feelings about
what happened in this [ __ ]
but
oh man i don't know if i have
the sound for you guys
to hear it
damn it
i don't know if i oh man i wonder if i
can i wonder if i can get this in right
now
if i can get this in right now
[Music]
baby you know yeah i do want to put this
in so you guys can freaking hear this
i just don't know if uh
i don't know if you're gonna hear it or
not but anyways let me just play this if
i can i don't know if you guys will be
able to hear it or not
jada i love you g.i jane two can't wait
to see it all right
okay
that's the joke
i thought at first
that this was some written thing but i
actually think that chris rock just off
the cuff
he sees her bald head and it's just like
makes a quick
g.i j reference
as i look at it now
to me
harmless let's go back again
[Applause]
wait
wait let's go here all right
you can't wait to see it all right
g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it
g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it all
right
so you're telling me
like i've been listening to people
been listening to people talk about this
i've been listening to people talking
about oh this was so vile
what
the dude looks over
he's poking fun at will smith
he he sees the wife he just makes a
off-handed comment like oh she's bald
g.i jane can't wait to see it it's
nothing
it's not personal it's not attacking her
the way some of these idiots on the
internet are talking about this is the
most vile thing i've ever seen in my
life i realize now as i look at it again
it's just an off-handed thing he don't
know about her history he wasn't
thinking about that he was just making a
funny joke in the moment
in the moment making a funny joke in the
moment that's it
that's it
and as you can see
will smith is laughing too because he
knows
and chris rock is even like what guys
it's just funny he's like alright you
guys didn't like that let's move on with
our lives
they act like
chris rock [ __ ] in his hand
walked over to the tour and rubbed it on
her bald head yo ball [ __ ] that's what
people are acting like
do you see
how
like
nonsensical this is
this is nothing
that's a nothing joke
nothing
it was
there's actually a thing going on the
internet right now will smith on the
arsenio hall show making a ball joke
about somebody in the band and then he
even says people go and he goes come on
y'all it's just jokes look that up will
smith on arsenio hall making a bald joke
it's just a joke
like the way people are acting
they're acting like this guy was like oh
like he knew in his head right then and
there oh you know what she got alopecia
so now i'm gonna attack her
it was a small little throwaway thing
that like we should have moved past like
this
that's what we should have done okay
right we should have moved past it like
that okay
um
will smith is laughing at it because he
even knows all right all right your
funny thing
you know jada says it she's like oh here
he go talking about me again
i get her energy like she's the butt of
the joke when you're the butt of the
joke you get slapped a little bit
it depends on how hard you get slapped
it's how we should react
this was nothing y'all
this
was nothing okay
chris rock's reaction
that was a nice one okay
so now he thinks all right this is it
let me move on okay i'm not even gonna
play any more audio from it chris rock
thinks he let's move on and then now
here come will smith
he comes up and he just slaps him
right
and then walks away
what
if we can now
after two days
look at this
and think to ourselves
that's why
you slapped him
wow
i mean
[Music]
i i'm speechless again now because at
first i
my first instinct was like everything
was scripted and because i wasn't
watching live
and like oh you know and then he had
this in his like
this is even worse the fact that it was
just a small
off-handed like
i can't wait to see g.i just like you
know you look at you know you know what
i mean it's like
it's unusual to see a bald woman you
know and jada piggy smith is pulling it
off great by the way and it's just a
thing he didn't know about her thing and
i'm sure if he did he would he wouldn't
he wouldn't have said that you know what
i mean
it's like
it's like this is ridiculous so now will
smith looks over sees his wife he's like
oh you don't really like this and then
whatever he's dealing with or going on
he feels like he needs to go up there
slap this guy
and then go you know say all this
nonsense about keep my wife's name out
your [ __ ] mouth
all right
now
let's go into this
when you are a public figure
this ain't new at the oscars is one of
the things i'm saying it's not new at
the oscars
and then and it's not new from chris
rock so you're at the oscars you know
the comics are going to do the things
that they do it is what it is it's part
of the game okay
all right so now
this is the thing i want to go through
the different points that i keep seeing
people make
the first point that i want to challenge
which i think is ridiculous is this idea
of people going he's defending his woman
all right and i've seen people say that
i was watching breakfast club and i
heard women calling in i need a man to
defend me like that i want that [ __ ] is
nonsense
i don't want to be with a woman
who would be okay with me
one
ruining the biggest night in my
entertainment career
my the crowning achievement of my
entertainment career winning an oscar
okay
i wouldn't want a woman that would want
me to do that for her
because it's selfish
the people that say that like you making
it about you oh i love when i want my
man to embarrass himself and ruin the
night for me
me me me me me ruin the night from me
embarrass yourself from me possibly go
to jail for me
tarnish this whole night for me
that's selfish so boom i don't want to
be with somebody like that rachel's
always telling me like she's like if i'm
in the car and i and i get anger
management likes yelling she's like hey
hey hey i don't like that i don't want
you to be like that i don't want to be
with somebody who's like that i get that
she's trying to make me my best i want
someone who wants me to be at my best
be your best be the best version of
yourself that's the kind of woman i want
to be around and want to be with not
somebody who's like embarrass yourself
for me
do me me me me me make it all about me
so i challenge that
now
this ain't even about
if you it's about not it's not about
defending your woman it's about how
when
where
again as you see that joke you replay
that joke that was nothing
whoo that was nothing
are you kidding me
all right
if you really have a problem with this
and you want to defend your woman why
ruin your night
step to this dude backstage you know man
didn't like that
and i feel like you always got a problem
with my family can we talk about this
because i don't appreciate it
could have handled it that way
two he could have walked up there
he could have walked up there and made a
joke he could have walked up there and
grabbed chris rock and been like man
stop talking about my wife in a funny
way but at the same time giving him a
little like yo dude like
enough of a like hey he could have
handled it that way
he could have made fun of him while he
was up there
all right
it's like
there's so many different ways to handle
this he could have just
he could have said that's not funny made
a joke anything he could have said he
could have made light of the situation
and still got his point across
he could have said he could have went to
her and held her hand like maybe it's
okay you know he just joking he could
have consoled her but no
he had to make a big ass spectacle
i don't mind
will smith
being
in the moment of like oh this is funny
i've been looking over and being like oh
you don't think this is funny oh i'm
sorry baby
and then having a reaction
how he reacted is what we're talking
about
there has to be a certain level of
decorum has to be a certain level of
of this is how you act at the most
prestigious event
of the year
i don't there's no justification for
what this dude just did none
if you're somebody that can look at that
off-handed joke and think that this dude
is attacking this woman's person because
of that
is ridiculous
and even still i'm okay with the dude
stepping to him backstage and being like
yo man didn't like that joke
it's soft
but i understand
now
i also understand the idea of like i
said earlier yo
let's not
let's not trash these sensitive ass
punks who are in the crowd anymore
because that's what they are
they just sensitive ass little dukes and
duchesses who think they're better than
everybody so they're thinking to
themselves
uh why are you clowning me and i get
that because i would be the same way if
i was in the crowd right
i wouldn't be sensitive about some dumb
little joke but i could get the idea of
being like yo
come on man why you clowning me all
right okay
so i i understand
but did but these people who were like
you know you talk about my wife i'm
coming at you like
you're a little [ __ ] if you feel like
that like really you for except for that
like the way some people are talking
about this yo man they talk about your
family the way they talking about it
they acting like the dude was like your
wife ain't [ __ ]
you ain't [ __ ] your kids ain't [ __ ] you
know like you act like chris rock went
into some classic chris rock rant where
he's going off on people that's not what
happened he was making fun of will smith
and going and he was like jada i can't
wait for gi jane too and then the crowd
had a reaction like oh come on and he
was like all right all right my bad he
even in the moment chris walker's like
okay it's just all right all right
he's he thought to himself okay i
misfired on that one let's move on with
our lives and he's even laughing here
comes chris rock it's like here comes
will smith and he's thinking to himself
you know he and never in a million years
did chris rock think this dude was going
to slap him
and then curse in the middle of the
oscars no way in a million years did any
of us even think that and that's why
people are saying like it's fake
let me just challenge this for a second
guys
the idiots
that think this is fake
let me ask you something
tell me what will smith has to gain
from this being from for doing this tell
me
what does a dude with
30 something million followers on
instagram
probably 300 million dollars in the bank
okay have to gain
one of the most popular men on the
person on the planet one of the most
popular persons on the planet
what does he have to gain from doing
this
what does he have to gain
publicity
are you kidding me his instagram is more
popular than the oscars
he gets more views on his things than
most television shows
he has
zero to gain by embarrassing himself on
national tv
that look at me
it is the stupidest thought
you could possibly have
and if it was fake
that is the dumb it like whoever's
behind that should be fired
it's not fake this was not fake this was
not planned
there is absolutely zero for will smith
to gain from this being fake okay so
that's i just look can we just stop
saying that okay it's ridiculous all
right
all right
okay
here's my other problem with what
happened
first of all chris rock is 57 years old
i did a video on instagram and i like
his stats are probably better than i
said he probably like 5 10 5 11 actually
he may be 140 pounds
57 year old man he don't do he looked
like a
slight build
he just had rotator cuff surgery i know
this because he was i'm at the comedy
store you know he had he was in he been
in a sling for two weeks
and will smith who is like look at his
instagram the dude's
always in shape you know he's an action
star so he's you know he's he was a he
trained in boxing and and whatever it is
this dude's a he's a he's an
intimidating person
right he'd go up and slap you and and
then like and and give it to chris rock
man dude handled the [ __ ] like a pro
handled it like a g man like a pro
professional took the slap and instantly
stayed chris rock was like you know
man chris will smith just slapped the
[ __ ] out of me he was in shock like what
and then he thought it was like man the
most you know he couldn't believe it
trust me
and then he tried to be like and this is
what comics do like i've been in
situations where i've had a really bad
heckler and there's a time when you
decide well let me change this energy to
keep the show going chris rock the pro
he is was like we are on national tv and
this is still the oscars and i'm about
to give an award to my man
quest love is about to get this award
he's thinking in his head maybe you know
i don't even know but he just wanted to
keep the show going and he did it
and my problem with it is
nobody came out to help chris rock
nobody
nobody
you know you know denzel and bradley
cooper would oh bradley cooper has a
tear in his eye for will oh will you're
going through so much for a off-handed
two you know two or three line
off-handed joke that like
does not deserve all this nonsense about
oh this is so vile
it was so
vile hey
look up the word vile
and you you think that was vile
you saw
nobody was there for chris rock no
security came out nobody
none of those hosts
comics were like yo man you okay nobody
came to his aid
no no producer came out nobody came out
to be like mr rock are you okay like
it's like you know what i mean nobody no
but nobody he was just there by himself
like he was at a road gig and like
there's no security at the club and some
dude in the crowd just came up and did
some stuff and now you're out here on on
your own and you just like you you're
like damn i gotta go to the hotel by
myself
nobody
nobody helped him
it's shameful man
and then they sat there let me tell you
something right now y'all look at me
uh
chris rock is a better man than me
i would have pulled my phone out and
called the cops
right there
i would have been a little [ __ ] about
it like yeah 9-1-1 yeah i just got
smacked uh turn on channel 2. uh just
got smacked i would have waited cops
would have came i would have stormed
right back out there he is right there
see him right there the dude right there
next to the ball lady him yeah he got to
go i'm pressing the charges right here
they should have escorted his ass out
that's what that that's my pettiness
chris rock was like nah i'm not even
gonna press charges he's like you know
what it is what it is you know what i
mean moved on with his life
not me
i tell you right now
chris rock got something to lose you
know what i mean like that's how i feel
sometimes you know you're out on the
road and then some people always like
talking and smacking being whatever i'm
like
forget y'all
i'm calling the authorities what am i
fighting for i'm about to get married
i'm 50.
what am i fighting for i ain't gonna
fight you know what i mean like if that
was me
i don't know if i would have just taken
the slap you know will smith could
probably beat my ass but i would have
got some hits in i'll tell you that i
would i would have grabbed you know what
i'm saying
i would have tussled we would have
tussled people would bradley cooper
would have had to run and get us you
know what i mean denzel would have to
come get us because we would have been
tussling
like what
i got glasses on too
slap me will slap me
i'm coming at you
i don't care what happens he might knock
me out
you know i don't know i'm 50. you think
i'm a fighter i'm a lover
you understand i'm a funny man
i'm just a big guy so i've never had to
really be in like a lot of altercations
because i'm a big guy i'm 6'3 200 280
some pounds
if
you know i've taken a few boxing classes
so i know how to give a swing
you don't want me to connect whether i
can fight or not you don't want let's go
there's no winners in a fight
anyway that's a whole other discussion
i'm just saying so i'm i'm just
disgusted with the fact that chris rock
was left to his own devices just sat
there
and no one did anything no one talked
about and then they and then 10 minutes
later this dude is getting an award
now
the moment that
the moment will smith hit this dude and
turned around and he had that look on
his face like yeah
yeah what what
and then he sat down and he had to
double down
to me i had to think that when he turned
around
you know
he had to realize oh [ __ ] i'm on the
oscars what did i just do
what did i just do
and then he had to he tripled down on it
by like you know keep my wife's name all
that nonsense right
and then everybody in that room was
probably like oh good finally the
comedian is getting put in this place
oh finally the dude hired by the company
to do what he's doing
he got put in his place
if you
don't want a comic there
hollywood stars
just say that to the academy people why
don't y'all get together and be like hey
maybe we don't need comics no more man
uh we don't need the comics to do that
how about if it's gonna be a roast comic
they just write a script be like here's
the jokes i want to say about will smith
here's the jokes i want to say about
jada pinkett and then like give it to
him and they can read it and be like
okay i'm okay with this and then they
boom and then the show can go on how
about do that
because even when ellen was the host
you could see people just being like oh
my god you know what i mean people don't
like being put on the spot you know
people don't like that i get that energy
guys i get it i get it
okay i'm not sitting here saying comics
should be allowed to say whatever they
want that ain't chris rock's show that
wasn't a chris rock special it was just
him having a moment being a presenter
and they asked him to be funny just be
funny please do the thing that you do
for like five or six minutes and then
get out of there and he did that and
then he was assaulted at work
if if um
if amy schumer had made the same joke
and will smith he wouldn't have smacked
her we know that
imagine that imagine will smith go up as
slaps amy schumer
who no no but even if he would have done
this even if he would have interrupted
her from his seat
keep my wife's name
it would be he would be vilified today
vilified
like this whole energy about protecting
your wife
it wouldn't have gone the same way y'all
this all this energy it would be
completely different energy if he had
just yelled out at amy schumer even the
other chick um not regina king who who
was the other host she made a joke about
their relationship they could have
easily been like yo keep our
relationship out your mouth they didn't
do that
he felt in this moment now the whole
thing's a tragedy man it's a tragedy all
right there's no winners there's no
winners in this
will smith i feel for him i honestly do
because whatever this man is like a
beacon of hope for everyone
not just black people man for everyone
he transcended color and race and became
a superstar
from bad boys on to all the things that
he did he became an icon in our society
we see will smith and we think joy and
happiness and this [ __ ] ruined
it
he ruined it
there's a time and place man a time and
place that wasn't the time and it wasn't
the
place not at all
he did more damage to himself
than anyone else
if you think he's a bigger man today
you're a fool
you're a fool if you're looking at will
smith being like i want to emulate that
no thank you
whatever demons and darkness that he was
dealing with in that moment it came out
in that time and chris rock got the
brunt of it it wasn't about that joke
it wasn't about that dumb
off-handed one-liner like it was nothing
off the cuff nothing joke
and for it to
to get to the level of him having to
stand up and go hit another human being
that is some other stuff going on with
him and i hope that he can i hope he
gets
finds
finds whatever peace and harmony so he
can get back to the person that we
believe him to be
i mean these people are public figures
you know will smith and um uh his wife
they out they out here in these streets
with all their business out so they've
been dealing with all the jokes and all
the stuff that's on them they wanted
that smoke
you know they wanted it
they're out here telling yeah we you
know open relationship we're doing this
and that and all this stuff and then
like you know jokes come with that man
that's what happens that's the business
of it
but i have to say again
this
small
joke
this small
off-the-cuff
thing
that he said
was not with any sort of malicious
intent
it wasn't malicious
it wasn't like he was trying to like it
was just
you know it's just like you know you see
a bald woman and you're making a joke as
a comic
you just being like ah you know what i
mean that's all that it was
he don't know all the things she's
dealing with with that
and so
you as a person need to know that i'm
gonna tell you a story personal story
and and i told this on i was just on uh
um
about last night uh adam ray's podcast
but uh this is my podcast let me tell
you i was at the laugh factory one night
and i used to have this joke and i still
do it sometimes it's a joke about like
these are crazy
because it's about gun control and stuff
but there's a point where i'm talking
about
there's this guy who like
you know he went to santa he was in
santa barbara and like
he was getting rejected by women and
he you know got a gun and shot people up
so i'm talking about it and i'm like
damn
this guy was rejected by women and i'm
like you know what i too
have been rejected by women but i've
never thought i need to kill these
[ __ ] that's never been my thought my
always thought was like you supposed as
a man when you get rejected you know
what you're supposed to do you're
supposed to prove them wrong
you know you uh you start working out
you get a better job you improve your
life so you can show these women that
rejected you look what you missing out
on this is the sentiment of the joke
what i'm talking about you know and then
i'm saying to you like so i'm like man
they rejected this dude so all you women
that rejected that guy and reject guys
like that
excellent choice because obviously
something's up with this dude you know
that's basically the sentiment of the
joke all right anyway i'm at the lab
factory one night
and i'm doing this
and as i get off stage one of the
waitresses comes up to me she's like
you're doing this joke there was a girl
in the um bathroom and she was crying
turns out
there was a girl that just happened to
be in the crowd that night who went to
sa to uc santa barbara and was a part of
that situation maybe knew one of the
girls i don't know the whole story about
her but she was upset about me talking
about this but you know how she handled
it
she got up and she went to the bathroom
and she handled it
because it was a her issue
i i don't know this for a fact but i'm
just saying
i appreciate that this woman
who and i am sorry that it affected her
in the way that it affected her because
it was personal to her
so she took her personal business
and she removed herself from a situation
of a group of people who were enjoying
themselves and don't know
and they got up and she left the room
as opposed to her standing up in the
middle of the show going this isn't
funny oh blah blah blah it's like who's
that for
you know what i mean because i don't
know
what i i have a point to why i'm talking
about this
i have a point that i'm trying to make
that i believe is valid
and she had some personal things going
on
that
it affected her so what she did was she
removed herself from the situation
that's my point about this
how the hell is chris rock supposed to
know
that in this moment this woman who's
looks glamorous and dressed up and out
on the town with the oscars with her
husband who's laughing and everybody's
having a good time that this little
offhanded joke
he don't know
you come tell him later yo man my wife
actually got alopecia and that's why she
bald and he might be like oh [ __ ] my bad
you ever think that that could be a
possibility too
but no y'all want to attack comedy
comedy
is not for the
and there's gonna be times where
you're going to touch on personal things
with people
but just because
i don't care about
what you care about
at the same level you care about it
it doesn't make me a monster
it's just not personal to me the way it
is to you
what are comics supposed to do at shows
now pass out surveys we're supposed to
be like all right tell me all the things
in everyone's life in this crowd that
you would like not for me to talk about
so you don't get your feelings hurt and
then so let me look at the surveys and
figure out what i can talk about so
everybody in the room is happy
take some personal responsibility for
your own feelings man
you know what i mean
like
it's just a show
you know what i'm saying
the oscars is just a show it's for
entertainment
it's it's supposed to be light-hearted
and fun
and this particular joke that's all it
was the man wasn't coming from some
malicious place he didn't even say it
maliciously he was just like
you know gij too can't wait to see it it
was just a fun little moment
and if you think that that was to rise
to the level where you think
oh you can't go after someone's family
if that's going after someone's family
man who
i i don't know what you're gonna do when
you really out here in these streets
i don't know what you're gonna do when
you out here and somebody really come at
you
because you're gonna get into a rude
awakening you know what i mean
and i'm looking at the chat yeah it was
corny somebody's like chris rock is
corny it was a corny joke it was that's
what i'm saying which is more reason to
be like listen
if it was planned out and he was going
in and you could tell that it was
scripted that might come across as man
this dude's being mean-spirited about
that
making an off-handed corny joke like a
dad it was a dad joke it was just a
stupid dad joke you gonna slap your dad
every time your dad make a dumb dad joke
no you just go ah come on man and that's
how the crowd reacted the crowd was like
ah
chris that was stupid and he went come
on you know he was like ah
i'm just joking and then it turned into
what it turned into
come on y'all
come on what are we doing
come on what are we doing as a society
man what are we doing
look at yourself
come on
come on don't fight just to fight let's
use some common sense man
like in your heart of hearts do you
really think chris rock was trying to
attack her alopecia
really
you really think that
you really think that what will smith
did was justified
in that moment
not only did he ruin his night
he ruined
the the the glory of the movie
the williams family that we're not
talking about them
we ain't talking about them we don't
even care we don't even care about king
richard
this didn't help the oscars
they just didn't do anything
but
it didn't do anything but like it was
just a dark day
and and on top of that
black men
like chris rock is hall of fame
comic
mount rushmore comic
chris rock is in the top four comics of
all time you hear what i'm saying
that's where that dude is
you can have a jordan lebron argument
with chris rocket whoever else you want
to put on the table
and he out there just no respect no help
for the man just left him there to get
assaulted and nobody cares
nobody cared that night
it's crazy
it's crazy
and for will smith like i said earlier
this man who is just a giant in our
society
who transcended race and color who tr
and even on his with his instagram he
doesn't come across as a rich spoiled
like he he's like an everyman and you
had kids watching this show children
it's a family show now people are out
here having to explain to their children
about you know is violence the way
there's so many implications of what he
did
if you're sitting there watching me
right now thinking
if you have this neanderthal thought
process of life you gotta defend your
family that ain't the way to do it man
there's so many different ways to defend
your family and by the way
you can't let words be the thing that
gets you you just can't
people aren't that important didn't we
learn that from covid didn't we learn
that our life is just
so much more important than
than all this crap
you know what i mean
love honor each other
be nice to each other we're trying to do
that and i know that comedy isn't always
that but you have to know that it still
comes from a place of
you know it comes from a pace of fun
you know even the pain that comedians
feel that we trying to bring out we're
trying to we're trying to make fun of
situations and show different
perspectives and what we do is when we
see those different perspectives we
laugh
that's the point of it
that's the point of it
anyways y'all you guys got me so heated
today that i didn't even do my mid-roll
commercials
so
let me just do
i gotta
i know this is crazy but i gotta do my
commercials for the end right now or
these people are going to be like yeah
do the commercials all right so let me
do my commercials right now then we'll
end it off all right but guys doordash
i use doordash all the time and i love
doordash you get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on your first orders of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the code what i like about
doordash is you can get groceries you
can get all kinds of stuff from doordash
uh the best part of ordering is you know
you you don't got to have pants on how
about that the door dash app is so easy
to use it arrives for you quickly and
then by the time you know
by the time the food comes you know you
you've spent time with your family and
friends or even if you just want to be
by yourself and you don't want to go out
into public you know what i mean
so with over 300 000 partners you can
support your neighborhood go to or
choose from your favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
cheesecake factory ordering is easy and
your items will be left safely outside
your door when you choose contact us
deadly for a limited time our listeners
get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app and enter
code griffin that's 25 off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code griffin don't forget that's code
griffin 25 off your first order at
doordash subjects change terms apply
all right guys i'm also talking about
coinbase which i use you know i first
started using coinbase when uh the uh
the remember that big when bitcoin went
crazy like a few years ago me and rick
glassman were in a hotel and we were
just like oh my god litecoin was blowing
up so uh i love uh uh
using coinbase and they are a proud
sponsor of the show
and cryptocurrency might feel like a
secret or an exclusive club but coinbase
believes that everyone everywhere should
be able to get in the door whether
you've been trading for years or just
getting started coinbase can't help if
you've been looking up your financial
portfolio and you're looking to like
spice it up a little bit it's always
good to diversify with not thinking
about cryptocurrency
it's backed up by the world's leading
investors coinbase keeps your portfolio
safe and secure while adding crypto into
your mix coinbase offers a trusted and
easy to use platform to buy sell and
spend cryptocurrency for a limited time
do users get 10 in free bitcoin when you
sign up for it today coinbase at griffin
griffin coinbase.com riffin griffin sign
up at coinbase.com richard griffin for
10 in free bitcoin the offer is for
limited time only so be sure to sign up
today that's coinbase.com griffin
griffin
all right
i got obligations
i got to pay the bills
so it is what it is
okay guys um
man that was something
you know that was something i gotta get
my i'm still a one-man show so i gotta
get my cord out
plug my cord in
turn up the music
um
anyways
like i'm saying
just
in closing about this situation
okay
this was blown way out of proportion
and just please try to take a step back
look at the situation and just kind of
be like
man it's shameful on all parts you know
what i'm saying
i understand all the sides
for people that are like hey man just do
your script you know just be nice
just be nice so people can get their
awards and have a good time if you're
one of those people that feel that way i
agree with you
all right
uh the other side of it is like people
who are like oh man that was like
you know uh
she obviously didn't like that and that
sucks okay it sucks
it was so it was so off-handed it was so
small in the grand scheme of things
but there's no justification
for violence against another person
and and on top of that the time place
location was completely
will smith was so out of pocket and by
the way he felt so too that's why he
apologized
okay
so for all you people who are in chat or
even watching this right now with this
attitude of like well you got to defend
your family all that kind of stuff he
don't even think that he knows he
embarrassed himself
he's the next day he probably was like
oh my god
the williams family
embarrassed his wife is embarrassed i
hope she wasn't i'm sure she was
embarrassed everyone was embarrassed it
was an embarrassing shameful situation
that should not have gone that way
you know there's no way and for you
people that like so many people like
well you know comics you you you got to
like take
you you you say stuff like that that's
gonna happen man if you're gonna hit a
comic
for saying something like that
then you need to just rush the stage
every time because that was nothing
there's far worse
and you just don't go to comedy shows
i'm just
let me just public service announcement
to people out here
who have a problem with comedy
don't go to comedy shows
all right just don't
if you're someone that is like you you
think that
don't say anything about anyone you want
victimless comedy just don't go to
comedy shows there are other people that
love comedy shows that's why comedians
you know they're on podcasts and and
they're making them on the road selling
out arenas and doing tours selling out
clubs traveling and doing that stuff
because there are people out there who
appreciate it and i and we appreciate
you for the rest of you that have an
issue with that kind of stuff just stay
away from comics
you know you see them on the internet
turn it off move on it's not for you
anyways
i appreciate you guys being here
thanks for watching the show
thanks for being here i appreciate all
the comments and everything that you
guys had to say
um
you know tough situation i feel for
everybody involved i wish the best for
will smith i wish the best for chris
rock jada smith the williams family i
hope the oscars
you know this should be a punishment
i don't know what that is i don't
necessarily think they should take his
oscar away but he might need to be
banned for life
or ten years or something where you
can't come back you have to have a
deterrent you can't just have people
punching
slapping somebody in the face live on tv
you can't have that
but anyways thanks for being here this
is eric griffin i really appreciate you
and this has been
the pursuit of slappiness
slap gate 2022 oscars
and this is eric griffin this has been
riffing with griffin and thank you for
being here see you next week
[Music]
this